und jetzt das heute journal
guten abend in einen das gespräch begann
um kurz nach 17 uhr unserer zeit und
dauerte 62 minuten
allein die tatsache dass die welt so
genau registriert wenn joe biden und
wladimir putin zum telefonhörer greifen
zeigt wie ernst die lage ist und dass
wir minuten zellen statt genaue inhalte
zu erfahren zeigt wie wenig wirklich
klar ist die usa warnen mit immer
schrilleren botschaften vor einem krieg
russland sagt es werde nicht
einmarschieren in die ukraine die
gigantischen truppen verschiebungen
seien nur ein manöver während die
ukrainische hauptstadt kiew zumindest
nach außen ruhig und gelassen wirkt
fordert jetzt noch deutschland seine
bürger auf das land so schnell wie
möglich zu verlassen axel sturm
berichtet
kiew am vormittag überraschend
beschwingt möchte man meinen eingedenk
der lage viele menschen in der stadt
ruhig und gefasst aber
kiew heute auch eine stadt mit zwei
gesichtern
zwei gefühlen der nachmittag auf dem
majdan sagt nein zu putin steht auf dem
plakat
ehrlich ich habe keine angst weil so ein
krieg nicht innerhalb einer woche
ausbricht
etwas mehr als eine stunde haben us
präsident biden und russlands staatschef
putin telefoniert man bleibe über die
jeweiligen teams in kontakt aus dem
kreml dringt am abend die antwort auf
die antwort sei fast fertig gemeint ist
der briefwechsel mit den usa und der
nato über die russischen forderungen
nach sicherheitsgarantie
währenddessen weitere manöver
militärübung in belarus 80 kilometer von
der grenze zur ukraine entfernt
wir sind jetzt in einer zeit in der eine
russische invasion jederzeit stattfinden
könnte wir wissen nicht ob präsident
putin das entschieden hat aber wir
wissen er hat alles vorbereitet um sehr
kurzfristig zu handeln die lage im
westen inzwischen als so gefährlich
eingeschätzt dass viele staaten ihre
bürger auffordern aus der ukraine
auszureisen auch deutschland das
auswärtige amt spricht außerdem eine
reisewarnung für die ukraine aus
deutsche die sich dort aufhalten werden
zur ausreise aufgefordert
diese zu erwägen die deutsche botschaft
in kiew soll offen bleiben personal aber
werde reduziert außerdem das konsulat in
den e tron nach levi verlegt am
flughafen von kiew war von massen
ausreisen heute wenig zu sehen
auch jörg drescher vom deutsch
ukrainischen forum bleibt im land sein
lebensmittelpunkt sei hier hilfsprojekte
städte und uni partnerschaften es gebe
viel zu tun
also ich sehe hier keine großartige gv
sondern hier in kiew ist das hier schon
immer ruhig am 2014 das ganze
losgegangen ist ja klar seither lebt man
in der kriegs angst also es gibt
argumente dafür dass die russen jetzt
einmarschieren es gibt argumente dagegen
wenn ich beides abwege denke ich mal
dass es unwahrscheinlich ist abwägen
bewerten jeden tag aufs neue
da bringen wir unser zdf team in
washington und moskau mit dazu selbst
der ukrainische präsident zeigt sich ja
heute irritiert über die usa und sagt
der beste freund für die feinde ist
panik in unserem land claudia bates in
washington wie viel psychologische
kriegsführung auf seiten der usa ist
dabei
klar ist dass der wichtigste adressat
dieser außergewöhnlich offenen und
lauten kommunikationsstrategie präsident
putin ist und jeder den dass in russland
sonst noch erreichen kann um zu sagen
wir wissen was ihr tut wir wissen was
ihr vorhabt ihr könnt uns nicht
überraschen
drei punkte dazu zum einen geht hier in
den usa fast jeder wirklich
parteiübergreifend davon aus dass man
das präsident putin nur eine sprache
versteht und das ist die sprache der
stärke und dass er nur durch massive
drohungen zu beeindrucken ist zum
zweiten hoffen die usa das ein szenario
das so laut in die welt hinaus gerufen
wird für russland schwerer ist
umzusetzen dass man also möglicherweise
russland einen strich durch die rechnung
machen kann bei bestimmten vorhaben
und zum dritten drängen die usa jetzt
schon lange darauf dass russland
deeskalieren möge aber auch heute in den
gesprächen hat russland wieder gesagt
der hat die einmal pläne dementiert aber
der aufmarsch geht natürlich
gleichzeitig weiter und diese diskrepanz
zwischen wort und tat wollen die usa
deutlich offen legen während sie selber
ganz klar weiterhin auf einen
diplomatischen weg setzen als ein sturm
ist in moskau axel immerhin wird noch
miteinander geredet am telefon heute am
dienstag kommt dann der bundeskanzler
nach moskau ist denn auf der russischen
seite irgendeine diplomatische bewegung
zu erkennen
das kommt ein bisschen auf den
standpunkt an wenn dialog noch durch
geht als bewegung dann gab es heute
bewegung auch heute wieder den dialog
hat ja stattgefunden
der außenpolitische berater von
staatspräsident putin hat ein paar infos
verlautbaren lassen aus dem gespräch es
ging vor allem darum dass die beiden
geschäftsmäßig miteinander gesprochen
hätten 62 minuten lang etwa und er sagte
auch beiden hätte durchaus die eine oder
andere zitat überlegung mitgebracht die
wie beiden glaubte den russischen
bedenken entgegen kommen könnten er
sagte allerdings auch dass der
staatspräsident das zur kenntnis
genommen habe und man das alles prüfen
werde sagte auch dass putins sich eher
zurückhaltend geäußert hätte denn vieles
von dem was beiden heute in dem gespräch
gesagt hätte hätte man schon schriftlich
bekommen am abend dann noch aus dem
kreml dass die antwort auf das schreiben
der nato und der usa vorbereitet sei und
dass diese antwort in kürze
veröffentlicht werden soviel zu diesem
thema heute abend hat sich ein dank nach
washington und nach moskau
wir können jetzt wieder wie früher unter
die leute gehen sagt norwegens
ministerpräsident heute sämtliche corona
schutzmaßnahmen sind in norwegen jetzt
geschichte auch die abstandsregeln und
die masken pflicht in überfüllten räumen
gelten nicht mehr das ist norwegen bei
uns kommt langsam bewegung in diese
diskussion hanna stufenplan ist hier bei
uns das stichwort zumindest wenn es nach
bundeswirtschaftsminister harbeck geht
wie genau gelockert wird das solle bei
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz am
mittwoch abgestimmt werden hp hat aber
schon jetzt einen vorschlag zuerst
sollen die maßnahmen wegfallen durch die
die meisten kosten entstehen statt zweig
oder zweig plus könnte dann das tragen
von fc2 masken ausreichen zum beispiel
im kino oder restaurant in einem zweiten
schritt könnte dann die home office
pflicht fallen genauso wie die
dreijährige am arbeitsplatz
beim besuch von bundesaußenminister in
bernburg in ägypten ging es auch um
waffenlieferungen konkret darum dass
deutschland diese in zukunft noch mehr
als bisher von der menschenrechtslage
abhängig machen will diese wird in
ägypten immer wieder scharf kritisiert
nach einem gespräch mit ihrem
amtskollegen shoukry sagte baerbock dass
ausnahmen von dieser restriktiven
politik nur noch in begründeten
einzelfällen und nach sorgfältiger
prüfung möglich sein sollen in kein
anderes land lieferte deutschland
2021 so viele waffen die nach ägypten
die sächsische justiz ministerin will
verhindern dass der ex afd
bundestagsabgeordnete jens meier wieder
als richter im freistaat arbeitet jetzt
ist klar auf welchem weg mayer wird zwar
zunächst einem amtsgericht zugewiesen
soll aber direkt in den ruhestand
versetzt werden dazu hat die
justizministerin einen antrag gestellt
der 60 jährige mayer wird vom
sächsischen verfassungsschutz als
rechtsextrem eingestuft nachdem er im
herbst den wiedereinzug in den bundestag
verpasst hatte wollte er zurück in
seinen alten job als richter
in kanada hat es angefangen mittlerweile
blockieren trucker aber auch in anderen
ländern straßen und städte um gegen die
korona politik zu protestieren
zb in paris am triumphbogen haben lkw
und autofahrer trotz eines verbots den
verkehr lahmgelegt die polizei setzte
tränengas gegen die demonstranten ein
auch im niederländischen den haag
blockierten lkw die innenstadt und in
kanada hat die polizei heute begonnen
eine wichtige brücke an der grenze zu
den usa zu räumen seit tagen war sie von
fahrzeugen versperrt worden
er hat 100 auslandsreisen unternommen
und 660 reden gehalten er hat dem
aktuellen zdf-politbarometer großartige
zustimmungswerte und steht gleichzeitig
vor der herausforderung die in konkrete
taten zu übersetzen macht hat ein
bundespräsident kaum er und bislang war
es immer ein eher wirkt durch das wort
jetzt ist frank walter steinmeier ja
keiner der den deutschen mit besonders
mutigen auftritten käme und besonders
unkonventionellen auftreten er
verkörpert den klassischen amtsinhaber
und manche fragen ob das noch reicht es
gab aber einen moment da ist steinmeier
voll ins risiko gegangen hat etwas
gewagt was keiner in dem amt vor ihm tat
er hat sich einfach mal selbst für eine
zweite amtszeit beworben als noch nicht
klar war ob er dafür eine mehrheit
bekommt das manöver dürfte morgen
aufgehen wenn die bundesversammlung in
mehrheitlich auch zum künftigen
staatsoberhaupt wählt frank buchwald
blick zurück
ein mann der pflicht die würde des amtes
bewahrt er grenzen testet er selten
frank walter steinmeier ist ein
disziplinierter präsident von anfang an
gilt er als kompromiss das charisma
seines vorgängers fehlt ihm die
kanzlerin von der cdu aber kann sich auf
ihn den sozialdemokraten verlassen
es ist ja die hohe kunst hier
weichen zu stellen einzuwirken ohne im
vordergrund zu stehen und dazu braucht
man einverständnis des politikbetriebs
2017 jamaica träume platzen bugsiert
steinmeier die spd in eine weitere
ungeliebte koalition mit merkel und
rettet die kanzlerin so aus einer
regierungskrise
demokratie sein leitmotiv im bundestag
sitzt da schon die afd und die
freiheitliche gesellschaft gerät ins
fadenkreuz
in hanau ermordet ein mann aus
rassistischen motiven neun menschen vier
monate zuvor halle angriff auf die
synagoge der stadt ein rechtsextremist
der schießt zwei menschen der
bundespräsident am tatort schockiert
also ich war im raum als der
bundespräsident mit seiner frau am tisch
saß mit den überlebenden und das war und
man hat gesehen dass es ehrlich ist das
war der vad ives berühren der hat
richtige fragen gestellt er und seine
frau die schwere eingangstür der
synagoge hält den schüssen stand und
verhindert dem massaker am höchsten
jüdischen feiertag
der bundespräsident greift das ereignis
auf wenn jad vaschem als erstes
deutsches staatsoberhaupt darf
steinmeier hier sprechen am jahrestag
der befreiung von auschwitz deutsch die
sprache der täter vermeidet er
wurden
zu diesem zeitpunkt kommen aus china
bereits beunruhigende nachrichten über
neues tödliches virus cupid auch
deutschland macht dicht lockdown der
präsident wirbt um vertrauen es ist gut
dass der staat jetzt kraftvoll handelt
in einer krise für die es kein drehbuch
gab ich hätte mir gewünscht dass der
bundespräsident in der korona krise
vielleicht noch präsenter gewesen wäre
aber man darf nicht vergessen wir hatten
eine omnipräsente
präsidiale kanzlerin am sonntag wird
steinmeier wurde in seinem amt bestätigt
die demokratie aber wirkt verunsichert
wie selten zuvor
und nun die lottozahlen von diesem
samstag die lauten 2 13 17 31 39 48 und
die superzahl 6 alle angaben wie immer
ohne gewähr
und jetzt noch ein ausblick und zwar
aufs wetter am sonntag scheint bei 5 bis
14 grad oft die sonne nordwesten ziehen
zwar wolken auf es bleibt aber trocken
im bergland und an den küsten weht der
wind stark und
sehr mild beginnt auch die kommende
woche dann gibt es aber häufiger regen
vor allem am mittwoch wird es sehr nass
immer wieder wird der wind stark oder
sogar stürmisch
der rote teppich ist mehr als unterlegen
promi schaulaufen in berlin in diesen
tagen er ist ein stück hoffnung
auslegware als ausweg die berlinale als
symbol das kino lebt und überlebt auch
die furchtbarste pandemie der deutsche
film auch und wie sagt unsere kritikerin
sabine schulz sie hat heute ihren
absoluten favoriten für den goldenen
bären gesehen ein film der neueste
deutsche geschichte erzählt und
aufarbeitet es ist eine bittere
geschichte
es ist kein bitterer film
eigentlich ist sie eine echte frohnatur
die türkische hausfrau rabbiners lebt
seit über 20 jahren mit ihrer familie in
bremen ende 2001 ändert sich ihr
beschauliches leben
was das sujet dass die mutter ihr sohn
ist im gefängnis
ich bin da wie mama vom rad wenn sie
fragen haben antwort ich aber eine nach
der anderen
um die user von schneeglöckchen ja nicht
ich habe wirklich versucht mich wirklich
an ihr zu orientieren an der rechten
jahrhunderts die hat ja auch so was so
eine sender live gutmütige art und ich
glaube
ist ein richtiges steh auf weibchen ist
sofort klar für sie dass sie das zepter
in die hand nimmt fünf jahre lang
kämpfte für die freilassung ihres sohnes
murat kurnaz er ist 19 als er im us
gefangenenlager guantanamo unter
terrorverdacht inhaftiert wird ohne
anklage ohne verhandlung ein schwerer
fall für den menschenrechts anwalt
bernhard docke
ich kann keine akteneinsicht nehmen weil
es gab keine anklageerhebung also
mit der busch verweigert ihrem sohn
gerade jegliche rechte wir haben
gefangene normalerweise zu stellen also
das system guantanamo ist eine ist eine
schande für die demokratie ist es auch
eine schande dass es das immer noch gibt
und das ist genauso eine schande dass
keiner der dafür verantwortlichen
politiker sich bis heute bei murat
kurnaz dafür entschuldigt hat chef des
kanzleramtes war damals frank walter
steinmeier trägt auch er verantwortung
dafür dass murat kurnaz rückkehr
verhindert wurde obwohl bnd und sie ihn
längst als harmlos eingestuft hatten ein
memo von der minister unsere regierung
indem sie anbieten kundert frei zum
herbst 2002
herbst 2002 das ist jetzt nicht der
junge sitzt seit drei jahren in einem
käfig für nicht wenn man es dann später
besser weiß sollte man zu diesen fehlern
stehen und auch den mut haben und die
moralische größe zu sagen das war falsch
das tut mir leid und diese geste
vermisse ich auch von unserem jetzigen
bundespräsidenten und ich würde mir
wünschen dass er vielleicht noch mal
darüber nach habe hier muss erfahren
dass ihr sohn später gefoltert wurde
doch dann hat der anwalt eine idee um
eine gerichtliche prüfung zu erzwingen
und was heißt rabia khodr steve george w
bush
desto gegen den präsidenten der
vereinigten staaten klar ist wer
vom bremer reihenhaus nach washington dc
zum supreme court papier kurz gegen
george tabori busch ist ein starker film
über recht und willkür und eine frau die
über sich hinauswächst großartig
dargestellt von meltem kaptan in ihrer
ersten großen kinorolle
absolut preiswürdig
ex präsident obama wollte das
gefangenenlager guantanamo auflösen
präsident biden will das auch es ist
immer noch da immer noch sitzen dort 39
menschen ein bewacht von
1500 soldaten
und das war der samstag hier bei uns im
heute journal
wir sehen uns morgen wieder wenn sie
mögen aber erst in alten ein mann im amt
[Musik]